vorrei riuscire in questo pochissimo
tempo a portarvi con me al 1606
nell'ottobre del 1606 caravaggio arriva
a napoli in fuga da roma perché aveva
commesso una cosa terribile omicidio
aveva ucciso ranuccio tomassoni e non
c'è bisogno di quanto questa sua
avventura questa vita travagliata abbia
alimentato biografie anche troppo
romantiche la verità è che a pochissima
distanza di qui un decumano inferiore
sotto lui lasciò una delle opere più
spettacolare che la storia pittorica
d'europa conservi e che la sua carriera
pittorica abbia prodotto ed è il quadro
delle sette opere di misericordia
qualcuno di voi forse l'avrà visto da
vicino qualcuno l'avrà visto in foto
qualcuno non lo conosce affatto
ma quello che appare da questo quadro è
che è un manifesto il manifesto di
quello che i nobili fondatori
dell'ordine volevano quel popolo vedesse
che cosa volevano fare in città
visitare i carcerati dare da mangiare
agli affamati vestire gli ignudi curare
gli infermi seppellire i morti ospitare
pellegrini e dare da bere agli assetati
queste sono tradizionalmente le sette
opere di misericordia quella che noi
conosciamo quello che appare inoltre in
questo quadro che è un bellissimo quadro
che ci commuove ci coinvolge e la
domanda è perché perché alcune opere a
distanza di secoli rimangono valide
ferme e ci coinvolgono e ci emozionano
sempre la stessa maniera
è una domanda che si sono fatti molti
intellettuali designer artisti
probabilmente tutti voi e sicuramente
tutti gli appassionati è una domanda
alla quale nessuno di noi può rispondere
semplicemente perché il nostro rapporto
con le opere d'arte così complesso e
così pieno di canali sensoriali che è
impossibile da codificare per cui il
gruppo di ricerca di cui faccio parte ha
cambiato domanda è si è domandato come
se è vero che ci coinvolge tutti come ci
coinvolge lo guardiamo tutti alla stessa
maniera
e allora abbiamo interrogato il pittore
che più di ogni altro si era
appassionato alle scienze ottiche aveva
costruito il suo laboratorio come una
mero scura aveva guardato la riflessione
degli specchi la rifrazione della luce
letto le opera il giovan battista della
porta e l'abbiamo interrogato con un
modernissimo strumento ottico che si
chiama eye tracker e controlla il
percorso colare di chi guarda le cose
abbiamo chiesto esattamente nel posto
dove caravaggio ha fatto la sua opera
dove li dal 1600 e 6 alle persone che in
tre giorni guardavano il quadro di
indossare gli occhiali e di farci vedere
come lo guardavano e poi abbiamo
guardato il loro tracciato è la cosa che
abbiamo visto è incredibile
abbiamo scoperto una cosa che è evidente
evidente basta guardare il quadro e cioè
che noi guardiamo le zone luce il quadro
si palesa perdono in luce per cui è
ovvio che sia così ma la cosa invece è
incredibile che abbiamo scoperto è che
indipendentemente dal fatto che abbiate
7 o 70 anni che siate inglesi cinesi o
che viviate in australia vessati
italiani o tedeschi guarderete tutti
nello stesso modo tutti con lo stesso
ordine tutti noi se adesso andassimo ii
e indossassi mo un dispositivo di eye
tracker guarderemo prima pero che
allatta cimone guarderemo tutti seno di
pero tutti poi guarderemo la fiaccola al
centro e poi la madonna in alto qualche
volta ci accorgiamo anche del mont atto
che trasporta le defunto però tutti
quanti rimaniamo incantati per molto
tempo sulla schiena dell'infermo in
basso e poi intercettiamo qualcosa
nell'ombra e se qualcuno non ce lo dice
non sapremo mai che sanzione che si
abbevera a una mascella d'asino questo
che vuol dire che caravaggio fu davvero
un regista un regista come gli storici
dell'arte ci dicono e cioè che dipingeva
dei frame laceranti che ci fanno vedere
i quadri come se fossero dei come se
fossimo al cinema come se fosse un film
ma lui fu il regista anche perché questo
percorso oculare è valido e valido in
quel posto dal 1600 e 6 ad oggi non è
mai cambiato e valido per tutti noi per
tutti voi e quindi la cosa che io vi
chiedo di fare personalmente ma che
tutti è permesso fare e quando finisce
ed semmai un nei prossimi giorni
andate al pio monte della misericordia e
lasciate che caravaggio un'altra volta
come nel 1600 e se vi racconti questa
che è una
bellissima storia grazie